-Our first guest
is an Emmy-nominated actor
and comedian who is hosting
the MTV Movie and TV Awards
this Sunday at 9:00 p.m.
Please welcome, Leslie Jones!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Leslie!
Aha-ha!
Come on, now. Aww!
Leslie, thank you so much
for coming back to the show.
It's always good
to see you, bud.
-Yes, baby, I love you!
What's up?!
-Thank you, thank you.
Now, I follow you on Twitter,
and I see all the stuff you do.
I saw that you got your vaccine,
so congratulations on that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You filmed the whole process
and everything.
That was very cool
that you did that.
You admitted that you were
nervous going in.
How did it compare
to what you expected?
-It was actually way easier.
I think it's good to give
yourself a very nice
paranoid fear,
so then when it turns out
less than what it is,
then you're good.
-Yeah.
-So, I was scared.
I honestly had planned
on not even taking it.
I'mma be honest, I was kind of
one of those people
that was like, "Nah,
this doesn't sound like
the right thing to do,"
but my aunt --
my aunt is
a drug enforcement agent.
And she put me on the phone
with a biologist.
And they was like,
"Nah, you gonna do this."
[ Laughter ]
-All right, good. I'm glad!
Good, I'm so happy.
And you look fantastic,
so good, good, good.
-Thank you.
-By the way, I love your
Uber Eats commercials.
Is that the one where
you're acting with yourself?
-Oh!
Yes, I love those.
Those were so fun.
-Dude, you're a good co-star
with yourself.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I do love myself.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We talked in the past about how
I love when you live tweet.
When you live tweet anything,
it always makes me laugh,
and most recently,
you live-tweeted
Zack Snyder's cut
of "Justice League"
with the hashtag --
-The best -- the best version!
Thank you!
The best cut of that movie!
-But you did the hashtag
#longassmovie.
Did you know
it's four hours long?
I haven't seen it yet,
but Nancy, my wife,
saw it, loved it.
But it was great?
-I knew it was four hours.
I was amazed that I was gonna
get to sit down
and watch four hours
of Wonder Woman and Batman.
I was so excited.
I was excited.
So I just I timed myself, like,
"I'm 30 minutes in!
I got 3 hours and 44 seconds
left!"
[ Laughter ]
-We actually put together
highlights of your commentary
while watching "Justice League."
Take a look at this.
-That's so dope!
Uggh, bitch!
That's good.
No, it's good.
I just blew out the whole side
of this building
that y'all been
going to school here for years.
You mean to tell me everybody
else under the water
got armor on,
but he got skinny jeans on?
Oh, he mad, fighting all
the arms coming out -- ow!
Who is he?!
See, it always come down
to somebody trying
to make they daddy happy!
Go to therapy!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Dude, come on!
It was so --
[ Laughs ]
It was so worth sitting through,
because Zack Snyder himself
gave you a shout-out.
Look at this.
He said --
-Yasss!
-Look at this,
"The official ZSJL whisperer.
I bow to you, my queen."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's cool!
-Yes. Yes, it is.
And it's gonna be even cooler
when he put me in the next one.
[ Laughter ]
-You think you're gonna be
in the next one.
But you told him
exactly what you want to be.
-Oh, I better be
in the next one!
I live-tweeted for four hours!
I better damn well
be the star of the next one!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I -- I think you'd be great.
I think you'd be --
What are the conditions?
What do you want to play?
A hero or villain?
-I want to be a villain.
I want to be a villain, and I
want to be the worst villain.
I want to be the villain
that people be like,
"Somebody kill this bitch!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-You have to do this.
When we talked about it before,
you said you --
I think you would be great
in an action movie or TV show.
-I mean, my knees ain't good,
but, you know,
as long as we get
a stunt double, we good.
-[ Laughs ]
Wait.
So you're like,
"stop, stop, wait, stop!
All right, let me get
in the car, hold on.
Slow down."
-"Stop, stop!
Hold on, hold on.
Let the knee girl come in.
Let the knee girl come in."
-Oh, my God.
I really do believe that you
would be great, by the way.
I want to talk to you
about this weekend.
I can't think of anyone better
to host the MTV
movie and TV awards this Sunday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You must be excited to get in
front of a crowd again, right?
And it's live?
-Oh, Jimmy. Okay.
So, you know I've been going up
so I can get ready
for the monologue.
And, Jimmy, I'mma tell you,
the first time I was in front
of an audience --
The last time I was in front
of a live audience
was when I taped "Time Machine,"
2019, September the 10th.
-Oh, my goodness.
-And that's the last time
I was on stage.
And when I got on stage,
I'm not gonna lie,
I got a little emotional.
It was, uh...
-Yeah.
-It was very therapeutic.
And I didn't know that that
was the thing I was missing.
-Yeah, it's wild.
Nothing like a live audience.
We have a beautiful --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There's nothing like it.
There's nothing like it.
Nothing like it.
And, Jimmy, I can't wait,
because this is gonna be
the coming-out party.
Like, we've been locked up
for almost a year and a half.
I'm about to make this
a party, party, party.
Okay?
I'm talking about --
It's gonna be fun.
Oh, my God, Jimmy.
It's gonna be so funny, Jimmy!
Jimmy, it's gonna be so funny.
-All right, I believe it!
I believe you!
Is there any celebrities
that are gonna be there
that you're gonna be
excited to meet?
-Well, I'm gonna be there.
[ Laughter ]
-That's all that matters.
That's the only rea--
I will be watching.
That's all I want.
Leslie Jones,
the MTV Movie and TV Awards
airs this Sunday at 9:00 p.m.